Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Chaos-Radio-Feed im Jahr 2024,
wo wir mit dem Chaos-Radio genau so weitermachen, wie es unserem Namen gebührt, chaotisch.
Das gilt sowohl für unseren Terminkalender, der so durcheinander gekommen ist,
dass es jetzt erst dicke Bretter gibt und dann Chaos-Radio und nicht erst Chaos-Radio
und dann dicke Bretter, wie es eigentlich sein müsste.
Was aber ganz gut passt, weil die dicken Bretter wurden auf dem Kongress aufgenommen
und das wiederum erklärt leider auch die Tonqualität, für die wir uns entschuldigen
möchten und die beim nächsten Mal wieder besser wird.
Jetzt aber frohes 2024 und los geht's mit dicke Bretter.
Music.
Herzlich willkommen bei Dicke Bretter. Wir sind jetzt leider taub für den Rest der Sendung.
Wir freuen uns heute hier zu sein. Es ist unsere erste Live-Sendung.
Ganz kurz vorweg, für die, die uns noch nicht kennen und das erste Mal hören.
Denn Dicke Bretter ist ein Podcast von Elisa Lindinge, Konstanze Kurz und mir, Elina Eickstedt.
Und wir machen uns hier daran, die dicken Policy-Bretter anzufassen.
Konstanze kann heute leider nicht da sein. Das kennen die häufig Zuhörenden schon.
Aber wir haben mal wieder eine Gästin eingeladen. Heute ist Bianca da,
um mit uns über ihr Lieblingsthema zu sprechen.
Unbedingt. Und Elisa ist natürlich auch da.
Ja, ich würde sagen, wir legen los mit diesem netzpolitischen Überfall.
Und Bianca, was ist denn dein Lieblingsthema? Worum beschäftigst du dich denn
so, wenn du nachts nicht schlafen kannst?
Ja, ich kann nachts nicht schlafen, weil es mir wegen der Digitalisierung des
Gesundheitswesens oder der Verwaltung oder beidem gleichzeitig.
Und ja, das ist so die Dinge, weswegen ich manchmal aufwache und mir denke,
es hat sich wenigstens getan.
Es muss besser werden. Genau, also meistens kann Bianca nicht schlafen wegen
den Policy-Themen in Deutschland. In der EU ist das meistens mein Thema.
Und wir haben noch nicht so richtig viel über den Bundestag gesprochen und wie
das eigentlich mit der Gesetzgebung im Bundestag aussieht und warum wir eigentlich
immer viel zu spät dran sind mit unseren Briefen oder vielleicht auch gerade richtig.
Und das wollen wir jetzt heute mal angehen und es soll natürlich auch um Gesundheitsdaten
und Digitalisierung gehen.
Und wir schauen jetzt auf ein Gesetz, was schon durch ist und deswegen hervorragend
für dieses Beispiel geeignet ist.
Elisa, möchtest du uns mal erzählen, um was für ein Gesetz es sich da handelt?
Ja, es geht genauer gesagt sogar um zwei Gesetzesvorhaben, die jetzt beschlossen wurden.
Nämlich einmal das Gesundheitsdaten-Nutzungsgesetz und einmal das Digitalgesetz.
Pauschal davon hätte man sich, glaube ich, nicht ausdenken können.
Und die jetzt vor kurzem im Dezember tatsächlich erst im Bundestag verabschiedet wurden.
Und die sind nicht aufgrund ihrer Druckfrischheit interessant und nicht nur deswegen,
sondern auch, weil der Ablauf des Ganzen, also der Prozess, wie das aufgesetzt
wurde, wann wer befragt wurde, wann was entschieden wurde, eigentlich total
so nach dem Buche passiert ist.
Wirklich beispielhaft, genau so steht es, so macht man Gesetze.
Und trotzdem kam Mist bei raus. Und ich glaube, deswegen verdient es sich,
da nochmal einen genaueren Blick drauf zu werfen.
Also auch ganz stark aus der zivilgesellschaftlichen Perspektive nochmal zu
gucken, was heißt denn das eigentlich für uns, wenn ein Prozess echt beispielhaft
abläuft und wir trotzdem offensichtlich uns nicht so gut Überfluss schaffen
konnten, dass wir da rechtzeitig Einfluss drauf nehmen könnten.
Also was können wir daraus lernen?
Bianca und ich und auch Khaleesi und wir alle, wir haben versucht,
noch unser Pfund in die Waagschale zu werfen.
Ich glaube, da kommen wir gleich noch drauf. Aber wir reden gerade noch an einem
sehr frischen Projekt und ich glaube, ihr werdet unsere Emotionen heute auch
noch ein bisschen merken, die wir mit diesem Thema verbinden.
Vielleicht fangen wir so halb von Anfang an.
Vielleicht wollt ihr nochmal so zwei Sätze zu diesen beiden Gesetzen sagen.
Was ist eigentlich der Plan?
War das absehbar, dass die kommen? Worum geht's da?
Vielleicht auch so in zwei Sätzen, warum sind die so problematisch?
Ich weiß, es ist schwer, in zwei Sätze zu fassen.
Aber vielleicht können wir das mal so, um ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen,
was für einen Unterschied es eigentlich geben wird im Thema Gesundheitsdaten,
wenn diese Gesetze so kommen, was sie hier tun werden. Ja, also ich fange gleich mal an.
Es gibt, wie gesagt, zwei Gesetze, das Digitalgesetz und das Gesundheitsdaten-Nutzungsgesetz.
Sie heißen eigentlich offiziell noch
viel länger, aber die Kurzfassung des Gesundheitsdaten-Nutzungsgesetzes,
ist schon die Kurzfassung von
einem Gesetz und noch eine viel längere Verbesserung von sonst irgendwas.
Aber im Prinzip geht es um zwei Dinge. Wir haben ja im Bereich der Digitalisierung
des Gesundheitswesens so seit ein paar Jahren bis Jahrzehnten in Deutschland
relativ wenig Fortschritt.
Und jetzt versucht man das so ein bisschen.
Von heute auf morgen irgendwie alles an den Start zu bringen.
Es kriegen quasi alle Patientinnen eine elektrische Patientenakte.
Sie können dann zwar opt-outen, aber sie kommen automatisch hin.
Es werden sehr, sehr viele Dinge vereinfacht in Anführungszeichen.
Man bricht auch ganz klar mit Grundrechten und geht von dem Test der informierten
Einwilligung zu einem Opt-out-Prinzip. Das heißt, alle bekommen erstmal, außer sie sind dagegen.
Das ist ein wesentlicher Kernbestandteil
des Digitalgesetzes und des Gesundheitsdaten-Nutzungsgesetzes.
Das Zeug ist dazu da, dass die Daten, die den elektronischen Patienten ab und
an gesammelt werden, automatisch, dass die auch der Forschung bereitgestellt werden.
Und ich glaube, das Problematische ist auf jeden Fall daran,
dass wir eigentlich, wenn wir überlegen, in Deutschland haben wir sehr,
sehr viel mit informierter Einwilligung und Selbstbestimmung und sonstigen Dingen
eigentlich auch mit den Grundrechten quasi aufgesogen und jetzt kommt sowas in die Richtung,
naja gut, jetzt bekommt ihr das mal und wenn euch das nicht passt,
könnt ihr dann irgendwie dagegen sein, aber bekommt das alle mal.
Und tatsächlich auch die politische Zielsetzung ist zu sagen,
wir wollen ganz schnell wirklich 80 Prozent der gesetzlich Versicherten erreichen,
plus eben mit einem sehr, sehr starken Fokus auf medizinische Forschung zu ermöglichen,
wobei nicht unbedingt medizinische Forschung im positiven Sinne,
sondern auch ganz klar geht um Wirtschaft und Standort und Gesundheitswirtschaft.
Den qualifizierten Ramp gibt es, glaube ich, jetzt auch noch auf dem Kongress,
oder? Du hast ihn noch nicht gehalten.
Auf dem gibt es, ja. Genau, ich glaube das spannende Knackwort,
das da immer im Raum stand war, das ist ja alles gemeinwohlorientiert oder dient
dem Gemeinwohl, ohne dass irgendwann mal klar benannt wurde,
was das eigentlich heißt und wenn wir jetzt über medizinische Forschung reisen,
dann kann es da natürlich einen gemeinwohlorientierten Bereich geben.
Und Pharma-Forschung per se ist für mich jetzt nicht gemeinwohlorientiert,
nur weil der Medizin rausfällt.
Aber genau das sind dann so Punkte in der Diskussion, wo das Ganze dann auch
sehr stark auseinanderging und wo gefühlt auch Zivilgesellschaft und das Richtig
ist ja konkret auch an mich zu spät drauf geguckt hat. Ich meine,
Berka, du bist da schon viel länger dran an dem Thema.
Aber auch so ein bisschen als One-Woman-Army habe ich das Gefühl.
Naja, ich will nicht sagen, dass es One-One-One ist. In Deutschland vielleicht ein bisschen, ja.
Aber ich glaube, das Thema ist schlicht und greifend, dass man das ja auch in
einem Gesamtkontext sehen muss. Also wir haben die deutsche Komponente,
wir haben auch die europäische Komponente.
Das geht ganz klar halt auch in Richtung von Europa Richtung Deutschland oder
andersherum und bedingt sich gegenseitig.
Und das ist, glaube ich, auch die Schnittmenge zu Khaleesi, dann im Sinne von,
ja, auf der EU-Ebene passieren Dinge und da passieren gerade sehr viele Dinge,
Da war Chat-Kontrolle, dann ist EIDAS, dann ist irgendwie DSA und AI Act und irgendwas.
Und dann kommt noch dieses Gesundheitsthema in einem dahin. Und irgendwann hat
man, glaube ich, auch als zivilgesellschaft, glaube ich, gar keine Zeit mehr,
sich auf alles zu fokussieren, weil es so viel ist.
Und irgendwie fühlt man sich, glaube ich, auch so am Ende vom Jahr 2023 so als
Zivilgesellschaft ein bisschen überlaufen von sinnigen oder unsinnigen Gesetzesvorschlägen
aus EU-Ebene, die dann irgendwie auch sich auf Deutschland auswirken.
Und ich glaube, bei dem Thema EDS bin ich jetzt seit März irgendwie mit dabei.
Und es war zu Beginn schon sehr düster, weil man ganz klar gesagt hat,
okay, wir machen jetzt erstmal einen Datenmarkt als Teil des europäischen Digital Market.
Und was mit Grundrechten ist, sind wir uns gar nicht. Das ist ein bisschen besser
geworden, aber es ist noch nicht so, dass man sagen würde, das ist irgendwie
auch für Grundrechte und Selbstbestimmung gut, aber naja, es ist irgendwie ein Kompromiss.
Genau, also es ist alles ziemlich düster. Jetzt haben wir mal so grob umrissen,
was jetzt am Ende dabei rausgefallen ist.
Elisa hat eben schon gesagt, es
war irgendwie, es ist alles mal so stromlinienförmig gelaufen, wie es ist.
Ich bin ja mehr so an Gesetzgebung gewöhnt, die so drei Jahre dauern und dann
ist immer noch nicht vorbei.
Das ist in Deutschland ein bisschen anders, was wahrscheinlich auch gut so ist.
Und vielleicht fangen wir mal so ganz am Anfang an, nämlich mit einer,
mit der Initiative von so einem Gesetzesentwurf.
Wie ist das denn, wenn wir jetzt beispielhaft bei diesem Gesundheitsdaten-Nutzungsgesetz
bleiben zum Beispiel, wie ist es denn da gelaufen?
Also meistens kommt so ein Gesetz erstmal, mal wird in irgendwelchen Ministerien
ausgearbeitet, es kommt dann meistens ein Referentenentwurf irgendwie zustande,
der kommt dann so als erstes mal ans Licht der Öffentlichkeit,
wobei diese Öffentlichkeit ist so ein bisschen, naja,
nicht die wirkliche Öffentlichkeit, sondern sind dann meistens schon irgendwie
Verbände oder Organisationen, die man da ganz gern mit anspricht,
weil das eigentlich Gesetzgebung für diesejenigen Organisationen ist.
Und das führt dann dazu, dass zum Beispiel bei den ganzen Digitalgesetzen.
Ich glaube, die Quelle des Referentenentwurfs, die wir als Zivilgesellschaft
hatten, war Netzpolitik Und das ist ungefähr auch die Einbeziehung der Zivilgesellschaft.
Also ich glaube wahrscheinlich haben alle Krankenkassen und Ärzteverbände und
sonstigen diesen ganzen Entwurf schon mal gesehen, konnten dann kommentieren,
du musst der Zivilgesellschaft irgendwie darauf vertrauen, dass es mal irgendwo vom Laster fällt.
Das ist dann auch so ein bisschen auch der Wunsch, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen,
dass man erst mal das nicht so ganz an die Öffentlichkeit packt,
sondern dass man erst mal so die Verbände, die davon betroffen sind und Ärztekammern
und sonstige mit einbezieht, damit die schon ein bisschen mehr in diese Richtung prägen können.
Und wenn man Glück hat, kommt dieser Referentenentwurf dann irgendwie auch mal in die Öffentlichkeit.
Aber das ging schon beim Gesundheitsdatennutzungsgesetz und Digitalgesetz auf
eine Art und Weise, wo man sich eigentlich nicht besonders damit rühmen konnte,
dass das ein besonders transparenter Prozess war.
Jetzt haben wir ja als Gegenentwurf ja gerade auch ein paar andere Vorgehensweisen
in anderen Bundesministerien, die ich ganz spannend finde.
Heute hat beispielsweise auch Anne Roth über das Thema digitale Gewalt gesprochen.
Ich weiß nicht, wer von euch dabei war oder sich das angehört hat.
Da gab es ja auch schon vor dem Referentenentwurf, also quasi vor diesem oft
erst so ein bisschen intern zirkulierten, vor dieser Entwurfsvariante,
gab es da schon ein Eckpunktepapier, zu dem es ein öffentliches Konsultationsverfahren gab,
bei wo man sogar, ich glaube, drei Wochen Zeit hatte, um zu kommentieren.
Das heißt, das war tatsächlich sehr früh und sehr offen. Also wir haben eine
Art von Gleichzeitigkeit. Die Häuser machen das sehr, sehr unterschiedlich.
Die geben sehr unterschiedlich zeitlich Informationen raus.
Die laden sehr unterschiedlich Feedback aktiv ein.
Und in dem Fall war es, so wie es eigentlich vorgesehen ist,
aber auch maximal intransparent. Und wie du sagst, wir müssen halt eigentlich
uns darauf verlassen, dass es am Ende auf Volltext auf den Medien unserer Wahl zu finden ist.
Aber das ist halt auch immer so ein bisschen nachgelagert.
Ja, und ich glaube, das ist auch ein wichtiger Unterschied, den wir irgendwie
in der EU sehen, da haben wir dann irgendwie immer diese offenen Konsultationsprozesse,
die auch relativ lange laufen.
Auch wenn das dann häufig ist so, bitte werfen Sie Ihren Textil ein und dann
können wir sagen, wir haben Konsultationen gemacht.
Ich bin gespannt, was jetzt am Ende als Referentenentwurf rauskommen wird bei der digitalen Gewalt.
Also da gab es ja wirklich sehr viel und sehr auch konstruktives Feedback,
inwieweit das mit einbezogen wird.
Da bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt, ob das jetzt auch was bringt, Weil ich glaube,
da sind wir uns alle einig, so Konsultationsprozesse, also sie zu haben,
ist wichtig, aber es ist umso wichtiger, dass die auch nicht irgendwie nur dann
unterm Tisch verschwinden und unter Akte B abgelegt werden.
Also da bleibt es weiterhin spannend. Vielleicht müssen wir dann irgendwann
nochmal Anna einladen oder Sina von der GFS.
Genau, aber Referentenentwurf wurde erfolgreich geleakt.
Vielleicht an der Stelle, wo wir gerade über Konsultationen und ernstzunehmend
sprechen, wie ist denn da so, also vielleicht kannst du es auch gar nicht sagen,
aber du sagst ja gerade, ja, an die, die diese Gesetze betreffen,
dir wird dieser Referentenentwurf schon gegeben.
Wenn die Feedback geben, was ist da so dein Gefühl, wie viel impact das hat
also wird es ernst genommen wird es wirklich mit einbezogen oder es ist so ein
bisschen so wieder vielen dank für ihr feedback und wir machen trotzdem was wir wollen.
Naja, ich glaube, man sucht sich natürlich auch bei was auch immer Anhörungen,
bei Verbänden, Kommentaren und sonstigen Dingen, sucht man sich natürlich auch
immer die, die schon in die eigene Richtung argumentieren. Das ist natürlich
schon so ein bisschen immer.
Also man sucht sich nicht unbedingt immer die, die komplett dagegen sind,
sondern die grundsätzlich auch schon diese Wünsche, die in diesen Gesetzen formuliert
sind, einem auch irgendwie trauen können grundsätzlich.
Ich habe schon den Eindruck, dass da immer so ein bisschen was rauskommt,
so ein paar Detailverbesserungen, speziell wenn es dann um Umsetzung geht,
wie dann das in der Praxis funktionieren soll.
Ich habe aber nicht den Eindruck, dass es irgendwie die Richtung des Gesetzes
wird verändert, sondern dass es das ein bisschen halt noch mit praktischen Erfahrungen anreichert.
Aber da sind so grundsätzliche strategische Änderungen meistens nicht drin.
Die sind aber eigentlich vorher schon meistens klar und die gehen meistens auch
relativ komfort vor, mit den Gruppen, die man natürlich Autosäuregesetze begünstigen möchte.
Okay. Das war jetzt alles, glaube ich, so ein bisschen trocken und juristisch
und ich glaube, alle sind jetzt auch erstmal erschlagen von,
wie Gründheitsdatennutzungsgesetz und EHDS funktioniert.
Hätte ich fast gesagt, du hast gar nicht erklärt, was das für eine Abkürzung ist.
Also EHDS ist die europäische Schwester, das ist das European Health Data Space.
Es ist genauso abgespaced, wie es klingt. Aber wir haben jetzt diesen Referentenentwurf
und du hast jetzt gerade schon so Anhörungen anklingen lassen und deswegen kommen
wir ja jetzt zu einem bisschen lustigeren Teil.
Anhörungen. Wann kommen diese Anhörungen ins Spiel und wie ist das eigentlich so?
Also grundsätzlich gibt es ja mehrere Entwurfsfassungen. Es gibt einen Referentenentwurf,
dann gibt es meistens irgendwie noch einen Kabinettsentwurf und wenn es dann
so ein Punktkabinettsentwurf ist, dann ist das so, da brauchst du das Kaninchen.
Also das heißt dann immer, das ist der Entwurf der Bundesregierung für irgendwas,
Das heißt, es ist dann so eine Fassung, wo man sich quasi auch intern im Kabinettgesetz
so geeinigt hat und sagt, okay, das ist jetzt das, wo wir uns drauf gemittet haben.
Grundsätzlich ist es aber halt auch mal vier der fünf von dem jeweiligen Haus, das halt sagt,
okay, guckt, wir haben jetzt die erste Fassung, da hat schon mal jemand Korrektur
gelesen, Anfangszeichen, dann geht es Richtung Kabinett und dann geht es erstmal
so den Weg der Gesetzgebung im Parlament im Prinzip.
Und da sind wir lustigerweise beim Thema Gesundheitsdaten-Nutzungsposition digital
gesetzt, glaube ich, es gab irgendwann mal Mitte des Jahres so einen Zeitplan
und normalerweise denkt man sich, Zeitpläne werden nie eingehalten,
aber komischerweise hat es da funktioniert,
was ungewöhnlich ist und laut Zeitplan waren wir da Ende August beim Kapitalentwurf.
Und sind dann, jetzt muss ich noch ein bisschen spicken, in der ersten Lesung
im Bundestag gewesen am 9.11.
Da wird das erstmal diskutiert und wird dann meistens in die jeweiligen Ausschüsse übergeben.
Und federführend für das Thema Gesundheit war natürlich der Gesundheitsausschuss,
der sich dann aber eigentlich dann halt beschäftigt hat mit einem sehr,
sehr stark digitallastigen Thema.
Jetzt könnte man sich überlegen, ja gut, federführend fachlich gesehen ist der
Gesundheitsausschuss, Aber weil das so einen starken Impact auf den Bereich
Digitales hat, ist vielleicht auch der Digitalausschuss noch irgendwie mit befasst.
Und man kann es natürlich auch beliebig weit reden, wie weit es dann auch Richtung
Inneres geht, Richtung Verbraucherschutz und sonstige Dinge.
Die sind da alle schon immer irgendwie mit tätig.
Aber viel dafür und eben der Gesundheitsausschuss. Und nachdem das durch die
erste Lesung geht, das ist immer das, was dann im Parlament passiert,
versucht man natürlich auch die Fachlichkeit mit einzuladen.
Dann gab es die Anhörung. Und die Anhörung ist ja spannend zusammengesetzt.
Es gab schriftliche Stellungnahmen. Viele sogar. Also ich habe selten so viele gesehen.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben hier von Krankenkassen wie die AOK bis über den Bitkom.
Natürlich Bianca.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du den Rekord
für die meisten Emojis in einer Stellungnahme im Bundestag geknackt?
Die ist wirklich sehr sehenswert, die ist sehr schön und ich finde die sehr
didaktisch eingesetzt. Insofern klickt da mal rein.
Wir packen sie in die Show-Notes. Ja, ich glaube, man muss auch erklären,
wie so den ganzen Stellungnahme eigentlich, also was die auch erzeugen,
glaube ich, von dem Prozess von, falls ihr mal an die Gelegenheit kommt,
an die Stellungnahme eingeladen werdet, eine Stellungnahme abzugeben, so dann.
Beantwortet die Fragen nicht, das ist das Wichtigste. Genau,
beantwortet die Fragen, aber strukturiert sie. eure Stellungnahmen nicht nach den Fragenkatalogen?
Nein, ich glaube, das Wesentliche ist, man muss sich vorstellen,
das ist halt dann irgendwie, man hat dann vielleicht irgendwie 14 Tage Vorlauf.
Das ist so der Vorlauf, wo man weiß, dass Ausschüsse irgendwie stattfinden.
Meistens sind die etablierten Organisationen, die wissen schon ein bisschen
früher davor, weil die haben dann den ganzen Tag Leute, die auf Policy-Arbeit
irgendwie arbeiten und wissen davon.
Und als Zivilgesellschaft kommt es dann meistens vor, dass du vielleicht so
eine Woche Vorlauf hast, offiziell.
Dann kriegst du irgendwie so eine Einladung per E-Mail von irgendeinem Ausschuss im Bundestag.
Übrigens hier, Anhörung so und so, Stellungnahme und dann schreibst du halt
eine Stellungnahme und die Stellungnahme ist eigentlich,
naja, sie hat mehr oder weniger viel Impact insofern, dass es ein bisschen auch
die Themen vorbereitet, die dann besprochen werden.
Aber ja, man kann tatsächlich auch, wenn ihr irgendwo einen Gesetzentwurf habt
und ihr wollt jetzt so eine Stellung nehmen, könnt ihr die auch so ans jeweiligen
Ausschuss schicken, die würden die auch mit veröffentlichen.
Wo kann man das die dörsen?
Wir können es mal ausprobieren bei irgendeinem Gesetz. Ich weiß bloß nicht, bei welchem. 2024.
Man muss aber auch sagen, man hat dann halt irgendwie eine Woche Zeit,
eine Stellungnahme zu schreiben, was eigentlich so eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit eigentlich ist.
Irgendwie so acht bis zehn Seiten ist immer so irgendwie ein gutes Maß an Input
und dann, manche zerlegen dann einfach das jetzt von hinten bis vorne und sagen dann hier ja,
das ist irgendwie gut, schlechter ist und noch unpräzise und aus der Erfahrung
von sowieso würden wir es empfehlen.
Da üblicherweise aber auch Mitarbeitende bei MDB Büros und MDB selbst und was
auch immer keine Zeit haben, ist eigentlich die Quintessenz dessen,
dass du auf irgendwie einer Seite gut prägnant darstellst, was eigentlich gut und schlecht ist.
Und so kam es auch zu dieser ominösen Emoji Stellungnahme, die ich allerdings
nicht für das Gesundheitsdatennutzungsgesetz erfunden habe, sondern für das
Online-Zugangsgesetz,
weil tatsächlich bei der Menge von Stellungnahmen die jeweiligen Büros,
um nochmal die wichtigen Punkte rauszufinden, einfach nur noch Beschäftigte mit Arbeit.
Deswegen ist das eigentlich das Beste, was man als Zivilgesellschaft machen
kann, das einfach so prägnant und kurz aufzubereiten, dass das einfach auch
schnell erkennbar ist, um was es eigentlich geht.
Das heißt, wir treffen uns nächstes Jahr hier für einen Stellungnahmen-Schreibworkshop?
Weiß ich nicht, ob das, kann man schon mal machen.
Ich glaube, das wird dem politischen Treiben schon ganz gut tun,
wenn es auch mal ein bisschen transparent und prägnant den Leuten darlegt,
um was es eigentlich geht und was
eigentlich in diesen ganzen blumigen juristischen Worten dahinter steht.
Ja, und ich glaube es aber trotzdem, du hast es mit der eine Woche Vorlauf nochmal gesagt,
nochmal wichtig zu betonen, dass das halt echt ein großes Problem für die Zivilgesellschaft
ist und das auch eine große Hürde, sich sinnvoll inhaltlich einzubringen,
denn manchmal hat man den Text ja dann auch nicht so früh vorliegen,
wie man sich das vorstellt.
Und ich weiß es selber,
dann irgendwie so 50 Seiten trockene Juristerei durchzukauen,
ist dann halt manchmal doch so nach Feierabend nicht unbedingt das,
wofür man die Kapazitäten hat, und dann auch noch eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit daraus zu zaubern.
Ich habe gerade mal die PDF aufgemacht, nur so als Vergleichswert.
Die ist tatsächlich 87 Seiten lang.
Also das ist dann quasi das Ding, was da kommentiert werden muss.
Und also man kriegt da auch ganz, ganz spannend irgendwie, man merkt halt,
wo die Organisationen auch irgendwie ihre Arbeit rein investieren können.
Also ich hatte irgendwie als Einzelperson irgendwie halt diese Woche Vorlauf
und dann, naja, sollte das halt irgendwie drei, vier, fünf Tage vorher da sein,
sonst hat es irgendwie keinen Impact mehr.
Dann bist du halt irgendwie so bis Nacht beschäftigt und stempelst die dann
quasi noch digital und stehst da irgendwie 23 oder 46 drauf,
weil das heute Zeitpunkt quasi fertig war.
Und dann guckst du irgendwie auf so größere Organisationen wie die GKV-Spitzenverband.
Dann sind es halt so 143 Seiten und denkst dir, okay, wie viele Juristen haben
da dran gesessen und wie lange haben die schon vorbereitet?
Und das ist halt einfach das Ungleiche, was du auch siehst, dass es halt Leute
gibt, die den ganzen Tag erst anders machen können, als sich mit der Gesetzgebung
beschäftigen, weil sie einfach als politische Lobbyorganisation dafür Zeit und Geld haben.
Genau. Und ja, also wir haben jetzt, um nochmal den Weg zurückzugehen,
um das einmal kurz zusammenzupassen, wir haben den Referentenentwurf,
wir haben die erste Lesung und dann haben wir die entsprechenden Anhörungen.
Und dann wird es natürlich in den Ausschüssen diskutiert. Wir haben jetzt hier
als Beispiel den Digitalausschuss genommen, genau wo es eben nicht diskutiert
wurde. Vielleicht ist es ganz spannend.
Also es gab durchaus die Ideen.
Also es gab nach der ersten Lesung im Bundestag, eben Anfang November,
hat das Ganze in der Stadt gefunden, wie Bianca schon sagte,
im Gesundheitsausschuss, eben mit Emoji Magic in der schriftlichen Stellungnahme
und natürlich aber auch geladenen individuellen Sachverständigen vor Ort.
Da war die Zivilgesellschaft exakt nullmals vertreten.
Auch das ist natürlich ein Zeichen und das passiert ja nicht zufällig,
wie diese Auswahl zustande kommt.
Hätten wir auch vielleicht nochmal stärker kommentieren müssen als Zivilgesellschaften,
darauf dringen müssen, dass das schon mal schief ging. Und dann war für den 13.12.
Nebengeplant, das Ganze auch im Digitalausschuss nochmal zu verhandeln,
im nicht öffentlichen Teil wohlgemerkt.
Und das hat dann aber so, wie wir hören, wohl gar nicht stattgefunden.
Grund dafür waren, so hieß es, die Haushaltsverhandlungen, oder? Richtig?
Also das Thema der Haushaltsverhandlung ist, glaube ich, ab einem gewissen Moment,
also man muss vielleicht auch ein bisschen so erklären, wie die Anhörung als
solche nach der Stellungnahme eigentlich weitergeht.
Das ist meistens immer so ein Termin von 90 Minuten, einer Stunde oder wie auch
immer, wo dann halt irgendwie,
Ja, 15 Parteien irgendwie in einem Kreis sitzen und dann hast du irgendwie gefühlt
auch für ein mündliches Statement zu irgendeinem Thema oder zur Beantwortung
von Fragen hast du nicht viel Zeit.
Also hast du irgendwie, sitzt du in einer Anhörung, hast du irgendwie vielleicht
irgendwie, wenn es hochkommt, Eingangsstatement von vier Minuten.
Das gab es da nicht, sondern das war dann wirklich nur und du kannst,
wenn du Glück hast, kriegst du Fragen gestellt und Fragen kriegst du meistens
von den Leuten gestellt, die dich einladen, weil die dich deswegen einladen, weil sie natürlich,
weil sie natürlich erwarten, dass sie die eigene Position untermauern, sagen wir mal so.
Das ist natürlich auch immer ganz klar, man lädt sich nicht ein,
die gegen das sind, weil das wäre ja irgendwie Kritik und das möchte man ja nicht.
Und deswegen ist es als Zivilgesellschaft meistens auch immer schwer,
von in Anführungszeichen der Regierung eingeladen zu werden.
Weil die Zivilgesellschaft ist ja natürlich nicht so einfach steuerbar.
Aber sie hat ja meistens auch immer den Vorteil, dass sie relativ offen und
ehrlich sagen kann, was daran schlecht ist.
Klassischerweise laden uns deswegen die Oppositionsparteien ein.
Genau. Und gut, da ist auch nicht mehr so viele, die noch Zivilgesellschaft haben wollen.
Also die Luft auch da wird dünn, tatsächlich. Die Luft wird dünn und man merkt
tatsächlich auch, dass durch die Auflösung der Fraktion der Linken da auch ein
sehr, sehr starker Arm vom Verlänger der Zivilgesellschaft auch weggebrochen
ist. Also muss man sagen, wie es ist.
Und es gibt noch so Ansätze irgendwie. Also ich hatte den Eindruck.
Dass es in manchen anderen, dass der Digitalausschuss sich schon noch ein bisschen
dafür rühmen kann, dass er auch mehr auf Zielgesellschaft zugeht,
das muss man ganz ehrlich sagen,
aber in den ganzen gesetzten Ausschüssen Gesundheit und so merkt man,
da lädt man halt seine Verbände ein und da will man eigentlich gar nicht die
Leute dazu reinhaben, die eigentlich so ein bisschen einen anderen Blick drauf haben.
Ich glaube, man muss halt auch einfach ganz klar sagen, dass wenn wir dann eingeladen
werden, dass wir es häufig, auch wenn es Ampelparteien sind,
dann sehr engagierten jungen Abgeordneten zu verdanken haben,
die irgendwie einen Weg gefunden haben,
die zivilgesellschaftlichen Vertreterinnen damit reinzubekommen.
Das muss man denen immer sehr zugutehalten. Die sind da gerade im Digitalausschuss,
aber ich weiß nicht, wie deine Erfahrung mit anderen Ausschüssen ist.
Da ist dann die Wirkmacht wahrscheinlich nicht groß genug, aber doch sehr engagiert,
die CW-Gesellschaft mit unterzubekommen.
Ja, also ich habe den Eindruck, dass es, es gibt halt Ausschüsse,
die sind per se noch ein bisschen lockerer.
Der Digitalausschuss gehört auf jeden Fall dazu, weil man da einfach auf einen
anderen Umgang so ein bisschen auch im Ausschuss selbst pflegt untereinander,
aber auch so ein bisschen, wo man halt schon von vornherein sieht, man ist irgendwie.
Angewiesen auf das Feedback von Leuten.
Und spannenderweise war ich auch im Innenausschuss zum Thema Online-Zugangsgesetz
und das war auch eher, man hatte so einen Eindruck, da lädt man eher Verbände
ein, weil Verbände halt diesen Thema einlädt.
Da wurde zum Beispiel für das Thema Verwaltungsdigitalisierung eingeladen der
Städtebund und der Landkreistag und so die ganzen Du musst vielleicht einmal
kurz sagen, was das Online-Zugangsgesetz ist. Das Online-Zugangsgesetz,
oh Gott, ist zu viel abgekürzt. Ganz kurz.
Also das Online-Zugangsgesetz ist der Versuch, dass man Verwaltungsleistungen,
wo es ein paar tausend eigentlich gibt,
dann hat sich beim Thema Online-Zugangsgesetz erstmal auf 575 beschränkt,
dass man die innerhalb einer Zeitfrist online den Bürgerinnen zur Verfügung stellt.
Das hat nicht so ganz funktioniert, deswegen gab es eine Anhörung zum Online-Zugangsgesetz.
Ist das parallel zur Ausweis-App 2 oder wie habe ich das so verstehen?
Nein, das ist tatsächlich die logische Folgerung auf das erste Online-Zugangsgesetz von 2017.
Und lange Rede kurzer Sinn, Innenausschuss. Normalerweise kommen in den Innenausschuss
halt einmal ein paar Juristen rein und dann kommen irgendwie ein paar Organisationen
rein, die irgendwie in dem Bereich relevant sind, Aber dass da Zivilgesellschaft
mit reinkommt, ist eher selten.
Ist aber passiert, war aber auch Opposition.
Ist vielleicht aber auch nochmal wichtig zu sagen, es ist jetzt schon wichtig,
dass zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen vor Ort sind, weil das OZG beeinträchtigt
natürlich die Zivilgesellschaft schon sehr stark.
Also das ist ein bisschen so wie bei den Gesundheitsdaten auch,
auch wenn wir jetzt nicht unbedingt die, naja, wir sind schon die Anwenderin beim OZG,
aber ich glaube, das wird auch manchmal dann gerne so unter Verwaltern verschachtelt
und eigentlich sind die Betroffenen ganz andere. Und total.
Und das ist aber, glaube ich, auch echt nochmal eine Kommunikationsebene,
die wir viel stärker bespielen müssten.
Ich meine, da rühmen sie sich ja sogar mit, dass sie jetzt hier Gesetzesvorschläge
auch vorantreiben und schnell und energetisch und es muss was passieren,
weil es ist so lange nichts passiert,
stimmt ja auch alles, mit ganzen gesellschaftlichen Auswirkungen für Gemeinwohl, ich weiß nicht was.
Aber dann reden sie echt nicht mit den Leuten, die es betrifft.
Wenn es gesellschaftliche Auswirkungen hat, dann redet doch mit der Gesellschaft.
Ist doch eigentlich nicht so schwer.
Und ich meine, wir reden uns, wir sagen das ja schon immer wieder,
aber das immer nochmal stärker zu forcieren und zu sagen, ihr könnt doch überhaupt
kein Gesetz diskutieren, wo zivilgesellschaftlich ein einziges Mal offiziell
an Tisch saß und ernsthaft Rede und Antwort stehen konnte.
Ich glaube, das müssen wir auch echt auf einer Meta-Ebene immer wieder reproduzieren,
dass der Reflex auch irgendwann mal auf der anderen Seite einsetzt.
Ja, definitiv. Ich glaube, da müssen wir viel so menschenzentrierter an ganz vielen Stellen werden.
Oh nein, hast du das M-Wort gesagt?
Nein, es ist auch wichtig, aber tatsächlich ist dieses, es war sowohl bei der
Anhörung zum Thema Online-Zugangsgesetz, auch beim Thema Digitalgesetz,
so dieses Buzzword, was dann, also wenn Menschen, die in diesem ganzen… Steht
das nicht in unserem offenen Brief?
Also Entschuldigung, wollte ich nur kurz sagen. Ja, ja, ja, total, total.
Und deswegen, das finde ich so spannend, wenn man jetzt plötzlich sagt,
wegen Nutzungsentzündung müssen wir das und das tun, dann denke ich mir so, ja,
aber ihr macht ja keine Feldstudie, sondern ihr macht aus eurer Sicht das,
was ihr für Nutzungsentzündung haltet, nehmt ihr als Vehikel für,
dass ihr eure Gesetzesprägung in diese Richtung schiebt.
Und das finde ich so faszinierend, dieser Abgleich von, naja,
also wir als Zivilgesellschaft oder betroffene Personen sehen es aber anders,
dafür sind ja so Anwürfe eigentlich gut und das ist nur so ein bisschen seltsam.
Okay, ich entschuldige mich für das N-Wort und gehe wieder zurück zu unserem
Gesetzgebungsprozess.
Wir haben jetzt gerade kurz über die Nicht-Diskussion im Digitalausschuss gesprochen
und ich glaube, kurz danach haben wir uns zusammengerottet und eine kleine Verschwörung,
die sehr erfolgreich war, gestartet. spät.
Es war sehr spät, also wir müssen, wir befinden uns so zeitlich jetzt so am 13. Dezember.
Wir wussten, naja, noch ein bisschen vorher, ich glaube es war der 7.
Dezember, als wir uns sehr, der 7., am 7.
Dezember haben wir uns dann zusammengefunden und wir wussten,
okay, wir haben jetzt noch eine Woche und dann gibt es die Abstimmung und dann
haben wir eigentlich verloren.
Genau. Und es gab im Vorfeld, hatten wir schon mal in Austausch,
wir waren in Austausch gewesen, wir hatten ein gemeinsames Positionspapier dazu so geschrieben.
Ich glaube, das hatte sogar Menschen zentriert im Titel, deswegen muss ich gerade noch lachen.
Wir reiten schon sehr lange auf diesen Begriff rum und hatten dann quasi basierend,
der kam vor der ersten Lesung raus, Anfang November, wurde marginal aufgegriffen, würde ich sagen.
Und dann dachten wir, gut, direkt vor der zweiten Lesung, ich glaube zwei oder
drei Tage vorher, machen wir nochmal ein Abend-Event dazu und laden wirklich
auch nochmal breit ein, auch außerhalb der Digital-Bubble, weil es ja tatsächlich
auch nicht nur die Tickis betrifft.
Wir müssen ja irgendwie auch unser unser Problem erklären oder das Problem so
verständlich machen, dass auch Sozialverbände beispielsweise oder betroffene
Patientinnen einfach verstehen, warum das problematisch ist oder was daran konkret problematisch ist.
Und bei diesem Abendempfang, das war dann die besagte Zusammenrottung,
als wir uns so zusammengetan haben und insofern aber schon auf ganz viel aufbauen konnten.
Genau, wir konnten auf dieses Papier, was ihr geschrieben habt,
aufbauen und dankenswerterweise waren relativ viele Vertreterinnen von zivilgesellschaftlichen
Organisationen auch an dem Abend vor Ort.
Und ihr habt diese Veranstaltung zusammen mit der Deutschen Aidshilfe gemacht. Auch das Papier.
Und dadurch konnten wir, also es ist natürlich irgendwie der Klassiker in deutschen
Gesetzgebungsprozessen, dass gerade wenn es um Digitalisierung geht,
dass die Netzpolitik oder die netzpolitische Zivilgesellschaft pöbelt.
Und mit der Deutschen Elfshilfe und den entsprechenden Kontakten habt ihr dann
aus diesem Grundlagenpapier, sage ich mal so, einen offenen Brief gemacht.
Und da haben wir jetzt wirklich starke Unterzeichnerinnen, sogar die Zahnärzte.
Nein, von denen sind wir glücklich.
Die fanden das ganz gut. Ja, genau. Normalerweise haben wir immer Probleme mit
den Zahnärzten. Deswegen war das sehr lustig, dass wir die jetzt auch dazu nehmen.
Die Zahnärzte sind immer das Beispiel.
Haben sich uns angeschlossen und leider, leider, also es war jetzt leider,
glaube ich, auch nicht anders zu erwarten.
Für uns ist das ganze Ding natürlich in der Abstimmung durchgegangen.
Nicht so, wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben. Das heißt, dieses Gesetz wurde verabschiedet.
Und wird dann, ich bin mir gerade nicht ganz sicher, was davon wie,
wo in Kraft tritt, aber das kann Björn bestimmt besser erzählen als ich.
Ja, also im Prinzip ist es so, ich glaube, man muss das immer vielleicht von
dem realistischen Erfolgen, sollte man vielleicht noch kurz vorher darüber sprechen,
bevor wir darüber sagen, nach dem Motto, jetzt geht das endgültig irgendwie
in Kraft und das ist alles ganz so, man hat nichts gebracht.
Muss ich, glaube ich, als Zivilgesellschaft immer die zu finden,
dieses Erfolgserlebnis, was hat man eigentlich erreicht und was ist eigentlich
realistisch zu erreichen?
Dass man jetzt irgendwie ein Gesetz stoppt, ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Man kann... Es kommt drauf an. Es kommt drauf an, ja. Also wenn irgendwas ganz
schlecht gemacht ist, dann kann man irgendwie dran rütteln.
Wenn sich aber irgendwie zumindest bestimmte Teile einig sind,
dann geht sowas meistens relativ schnell durch.
Man kann aber auf Detailverbesserungen immer irgendwie hinarbeiten.
Das ist zumindest das, was geht.
Auch das war beim Thema Gesundheitsdaten- und Nutzungsgesetz und Digitalgesetz nur bedingt der Fall.
Was aber zumindest bemerkenswert war, dass wenn jetzt Karl Lauterbach an seinem
großen Tag in der zweiten Lesung vorstellt nach dem Motto, er hält die Rede
zum jeweiligen Gesetz und genau dann kommt der Zwischenfall.
Und auch dann sagt niemand, aber die Zivilgesellschaft hat gesagt, das, das, das.
Und da hast du bist dann zumindest am richtigen Moment präsent.
Gesagt übrigens, naja, wir sehen das nicht so ganz alles in schönen bunten Farben
und alles wird super, sondern da gibt es schon auch Dinge, die sind essentiell irgendwie kaputt.
Und da würden wir schon mal gerne darauf hinweisen.
Und ich glaube, das war schon insofern für die Zeit und auch die improvisierte
Art und Weise, wie wir das vorbereitet haben, glaube ich, schon auch ein Erfolg.
Ich glaube, wichtig ist, dass man dann auch offenkundig klarmacht, dass wir diesen Prozess.
Naja, sehr kritisch begleiten, dass es kein Selbstläufer ist und dass es immer
auch heißt, okay, Gesetze sind eins, aber dass wir das umsetzen,
dass wir das auch tatsächlich zu den Leuten bringen,
das muss man konstant begleiten und auch kritisch begleiten,
weil sonst wird das ein System, das an den Leuten vorbeigeht.
Und ich glaube, das war in dem Moment schon auch gut, wie es ankam.
Es ist aber jetzt natürlich nicht so, dass man sagt, okay, jetzt haben sich
die Abstimmungen komplett geändert.
Das war auch nicht zu erwarten. Aber vielleicht können wir das ja so ein bisschen als unser,
wir können ja jetzt mal reflektieren, was wir als Zivilgesellschaft auch jetzt aus diesem Learning,
dass wir wissen, dass wir eigentlich sehr schlagkräftig sein können mit den
entsprechend auch den fachlichen Verbänden oder den fachlich zivilgesellschaftlichen
Organisationen, die nicht netzpolitisch
sind, aber fachlich mit dem Gesetz entsprechend verbunden sind.
Was wir jetzt daraus mitnehmen, was wir anders machen?
Ja, ich glaube, also erstmal die Tatsache, dass wir so strukturell und frühzeitig
zusammenarbeiten, ist glaube ich echt radikal neu, aber wir versuchen es halt
zum Standard zu machen und ich glaube, das ist essentiell, um dieses,
jetzt kommen die Datenschützer wieder,
dieses Augenrollen einfach mal unmöglich zu machen, weil wir halt nicht,
also nur weil wir einfach in eine andere Zusammenstellung, in eine andere Konstellation
kommen. Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich ein total wichtiger Punkt.
Ja, und ich glaube, das ist auch ein Learning, Dingen auch aus der Chatkontrolle zum Beispiel,
dass es halt einfach auch auf der anderen Seite nicht die Kapazitäten gibt,
sich mit dem technischen Aspekt auseinandersetzen zu setzen,
wie es aus unserer Perspektive auch nicht die Erfahrung und das Wissen gibt,
wie es jetzt zum Beispiel aus Sicht der Deutschen Aidshilfe aussieht,
wenn man auf dieses Thema blickt.
Und dass es aber eine sehr wichtige Perspektive ist, um ein gutes Gesetz dabei rauszukommen.
Also wir nehmen uns das vielleicht vor fürs nächste Jahr, dass wir das ordentlich
machen. Also ordentlich machen wir es immer auch. Genau, frühzeitiger.
Und ja, ich glaube ...
Was es aber trotzdem immer gibt, ist natürlich irgendwie einen qualifizierten
Rant über den Stand der deutschen Digitalisierung.
Wir haben ja irgendwie in unseren Ursprungsankündigungen, haben wir mal gesagt,
wir gucken auch mal auf 2024 und ich glaube, wer könnte besser qualifizierter ranten als Elisa? Oi!
Ja, oder? Und ich wollte heute so konstruktiv sein. Ja, aber du bist immer sehr
konstruktiv und das kannst du mal erzählen.
Uns so da bevorsteht. Ich kann ja mal anfangen.
Also das Gesetz für digitale Gewalt, bei dem wir den Referentenentwurf erwarten,
das wurde jetzt schon mehrfach erwähnt.
Da sind wir sehr gespannt drauf und hoffen einfach, dass dieses Konsultationsverfahren
irgendwie ernst gemeint war und irgendwas mit diesem sehr ausdrucksstarken Feedback
und ich glaube auch sehr konstruktiven Feedback, das eingereicht wurde,
dass das aufgegriffen wird.
Also dass das tatsächlich kein reines Lippenbekenntnis war, sondern wirklich
auch jetzt sich niederschlägt im Wording am Ende.
Du hast das vorhin auch gesagt, zu sagen, es ist irgendwie alles schlecht.
Damit kann natürlich die Politik und die Leute, die da irgendwie sitzen und
jetzt vielleicht noch einzelne Wörter ändern können, auch wenig anfangen mit
so einer Fundamentalkritik, sondern wirklich zu schauen, was daran können wir
dann noch retten? Was sind denn die Stellschrauben, die wir noch bewegen können?
Das ist das eine. Und das andere, ja, also klar, 2023 war jetzt nicht irgendwie
irgendwie von den großen Erfolgen gesät und ich würde gerne freundlich und nachdrücklich,
die Ampel darin erinnern, dass sie tatsächlich einen viel verstrechenden Koalitionsvertrag hatten.
Auch dazu gab es im Chaosradio hat man eine Folge gemacht zur Halbzeitbilanz,
wir haben ein Zwischenzeugnis ausgestellt, in dem es hieß, es war nicht alles
schlecht, aber gibt doch durchaus Luft nach oben.
Ich glaube, das hat sich nicht so stark verschoben.
Und ich meine, in dem Koalitionsvertrag standen Sachen drin wie,
wir wollen ein Recht auf Verschlüsselung einführen.
Das wäre doch immer was, was ich mir für 2024 wünsche. Und ich glaube,
da müssen wir aber auch alle nochmal laut werden, nochmal daran erinnern. So, hey, was ist damit?
Thema Koalitionsvertrag. Wann können wir damit rechnen? Wann können wir die ersten Entwürfe sehen?
All diese Geschichten auch wirklich nochmal einfordern, nicht nur gegen die
Dinge zu sein, die wir schlecht finden, sondern auch die Dinge,
die wir gut finden und die wir gerne realisiert sehen würden,
nochmal aktiv einzufordern.
Aber ich bin gespannt auf deinen Rant.
Oh Gott. Nee, also ich glaube, das Thema, was wir sehen, ist,
dass wir jetzt nicht mehr in dieser Phase sind von wegen, man kann sich hinter
diesen ganzen Sachen verstecken.
Bzw. im Bereich Gesundheit, auch im Bereich Verwaltung sowieso,
aber da passiert weniger.
Es ist so, dass man jetzt halt an dem Punkt ist, wo es auch keine Entschuldigungen
mehr gibt für, das geht nicht wegen sowieso, sondern man hat im Bereich Gesundheitsdigitalisierung,
jetzt ganz klar gemerkt, da hat sich jemand ein Gesetz geschaffen,
um auch mal ein ganz bestimmtes System durchzudrücken.
Und wenn irgendwas davon intransparent läuft, wenn irgendwas davon irgendwie
so vertuscht wird, wenn irgendwas davon schiefläuft, dann sind die Leute jetzt
tatsächlich in der Haftung, das als in ihr in die Verantwortung zu nehmen.
Das ist einerseits mit der Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es schiefgehen wird,
wenn man auf die Geschichte der Digitalisierung des deutschen Gesundheitswesens
guckt, nicht so sehr tröstlich, aber es schafft zumindest klare Fronten, von wegen,
man kann sich dann nicht mehr dahinter irgendwie den Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten
oder den IT-Security-Leuten verstecken, sondern dann jetzt, dass ich,
okay, ihr wollt das so haben, ihr wollt das so durchgezogen.
Und wenn es gegen die Wand fährt, seid ihr schuld.
Und wenn wir es danach kaputt machen, auch. Auch dann. Und ich glaube,
das ist zumindest im Sinne von dem Moment,
dass wir jetzt an einem Punkt sind, entweder geht das, ich glaube es mal nicht,
aber ich habe da durchaus auch Erfahrungen mit, aber entweder geht das so durch
oder man merkt halt, dass es so nicht mehr funktioniert.
Und da muss man, glaube ich, für neu überlegen, wie man sowas überhaupt gemeinsam zustande bringt.
Und ich glaube, dieser Weg von wir machen digitale Infrastrukturen und Systeme
und sonstige Dinge per Gesetz funktioniert nicht.
Das funktioniert nur in einem Prozess von gemeinschaftlicher Arbeit.
Was wollen wir eigentlich?
Wo gibt es Dinge, da können wir nicht alles haben, sondern müssen uns auf einigen.
Und diesen gesellschaftlichen Konsens von wie soll denn das im Digitalen funktionieren
in Verwaltung und Gesundheitswesen.
Den haben wir meistens ja nicht so wirklich, sondern es ist immer so dieses,
ja, hier ist ein Gesetz und jetzt sagt man noch irgendwie zwei,
drei Sachen, was für ihn gut oder schlecht ist, wir können es nicht mehr komplett verändern.
Ich glaube, wir müssen da halt irgendwann merken, dass wir mit diesem immer
gegen die Wand fahren, irgendwann nicht mehr so weit kommen.
Und dann spätestens in dem Moment sind wir halt an dem neu drüber nachdenken,
wie kommen wir eigentlich zu einer gemeinschaftlichen Lösung.
Ja, also Try and Error ist da nicht die Lösung, sondern anscheinend ein bisschen mehr Weitsicht.
Was ich mir auch hoffe, ja. Schwierig.
Ähm, ich glaube, ich erhoffe mir, dass wir, wenn wir mehr interdisziplinärer
arbeiten als Zivilgesellschaft,
wir bessere Chancen haben und es nicht mehr dieses Narrativ von die Netzpolitik,
die Datenschützer und so weiter gibt, sondern dass wir es schaffen,
unsere Expertisen sozusagen zu verknüpfen und vor allen Dingen auch verstehen,
dass wir unsere technische Expertise da auch nicht nur sozusagen äußern müssen
in Form von Stellungnahmen, sondern auch so ein Stück weit zur Verfügung stellen müssen,
um da gute konstruktive Vorschläge zu machen.
Und ich erhoffe mir ja auch von diesem Podcast,
den wir hier machen, dass es einfach für die zivilgesellschaftlichen Akteurinnen
oder Menschen, die sich gerne engagieren möchten,
ein bisschen weniger Frustration gibt und ein bisschen mehr Verständnis dafür,
wie lang oder kurz die Prozesse sind und wie sinn- oder nicht sinnvoll es ist,
sich an bestimmten Stellen einzubringen.
Und ich glaube, aus digitaler oder Netzpolitik-Sicht war ja das eigentlich unsere
Traumampel irgendwann mal, in Anführungsstrichen.
Und ich finde es ganz schön bitter. Also ja, sie mussten auch ziemlich viel
Mist ausbaden, das muss man ja auch immer sagen.
Aber ich finde es wirklich bitter, dass sie jetzt eigentlich digitalpolitisch
hätten durchregieren können, sage ich immer so, weil sehr vielen Themen sind
wir uns einig. Und sie ist einfach, verdammt nochmal, nicht shuffle.
Und wenn ich mir wirklich was wünschen könnte, wäre es, dass sie das Ruder doch
mal rumreißen und irgendwie es hinkriegen, alles, was sie mal versprochen haben,
umzusetzen. Das ist total utopisch.
Aber man kann ja noch Hoffnung haben.
Und ja, ich glaube, damit sind wir am Ende.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart, seid, wiederkommt. Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Es wird sicherlich noch etwas zu tun geben, wo wir konspirativ zusammenkommen.
Wir haben die Hoffnung nicht aufgegeben.
Das muss man sagen. Wir haben die Hoffnung nicht aufgegeben.
Dass wir konspirativ zusammenkommen, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Und dass wir auch weiter zusammen dicke Bretter bohren.
Danke euch, dass ihr dabei wart.
Music.